lo que vemos una vez más en los pueblos
que están en el frente en jarque estamos
en verjas y es destrucción esta casa de
la cultura fue bombardeada hace unas
semanas y hasta aquí hay una guitarra
que está destrozada que estaba en este
edificio que se estaba utilizando para
ayuda humanitaria la industria de esta
zona ha sido destrozada por esos misiles
y la agricultura está en zonas que están
ocupadas por el ejército ruso es lo que
vemos una y otra vez en todas estas
zonas del norte de jarquín en este
frente donde la guerra no se libra en
las trincheras se libra calle por calle
y es una batalla entre grupos especiales
que luchan calle por calle y batallones
que están en la otra frontera en
bélgorod selenski ya lo ha dicho no se
puede ganar a rusia en esta guerra en
otro sitio que no sea en el campo de
batalla por eso sigue pidiendo ayuda y
armas a los socios
internacionales lo que vemos
ciudades es una necesidad de ayuda
humanitaria muy alarmante hay muy pocos
vecinos en la calle y según nos informan
las autoridades locales los bombardeos
se suelen suceder a partir de las 8 de
la noche que es cuando los pocos vecinos
que quedan aquí se resguardan en sus
refugios para evitar ser un objetivo de
esos misiles que lanza el ejército ruso